what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to pop culture explained
so one division has taken the world by
storm with fans sleuthing through even
the smallest crown of comic book history
to formulate and discuss countless
theories online now i of course
have my favorites but i wanted to put
together a list of my top five one
division theories
currently out there at the moment so
this is exactly that
the top five theories on one division
out there right now
so starting off at number five we have a
theory that i think would be awesome
if it were true but i think the
likelihood of it happening is actually
pretty low so this comes from episode
number five where monica mentions a
friend of hers that's an aerospace
engineer and has led several people to
theorize that the identity of this
aerospace engineer is reed richards of
the fantastic four
and there are several things that
support this theory first we have
elizabeth olsen claiming in an interview
with tv line that there'll be a cameo in
the series that will be on the level of
luke skywalker appearing in the second
season of the mandalorian which was
amazing and then you have tiana paris
who plays monica rambo
talking of the reveal of the aerospace
engineer as something that she cannot
wait for fans to see
so both of these suggest that the
aerospace engineer is going to be a big
deal which leads me to believe that the
person we saw monica meet up with in
episode number seven was
not the person she's referring to in the
interview because that's not a character
fans would be expected to have any kind
of reaction to i know i didn't but
bringing reid richards into the mcu
would absolutely
fit that bill and it would make sense
for reed to be an aerospace engineer
in the mcu as it would closely mirror
his origin and marvel comics now for
those of you guys who don't know and i
don't know anybody who doesn't know but
for those of you guys who don't know
reed richards had designed a space
shuttle and after the mission was
scrubbed he and his friends piloted the
craft into space and came into contact
with cosmic radiation and that's how the
fantastic four gained their powers now
according to the daily dot
proponents of this theory also point to
the format of episode number seven
as a take on the mockumentary style
sitcom that gained popularity in the
mid-2000s the most popular of these
shows
was the office which launched the career
of john krasinski an actor that many
fans have been championing as the best
choice to play reed richards in the mcu
which i wholeheartedly agree with but
regardless
a lot of fans think that using this
style of show for an episode is a hint
that john krasinski will be showing up
but i don't think
this is likely to happen and here's the
reason why first it only makes sense
that this style of sitcom would be
utilized for an episode as the entire
series has basically just been a send-up
of different types of shows and sitcoms
throughout history so
i think reading anything into them
utilizing the mockumentary style
simply isn't justified because it was so
incredibly popular in the mid-2000s
furthermore i just don't see them using
wand division or really any disney plus
series at all to introduce reed richers
for one
i think it's just too early to introduce
the fantastic four as their movie is not
going to come out until phase five so we
got about three or four years and reed
richards is simply just
too big of a character to put on a
disney plus series when the fantastic
four make their way to the mcu
i think it's gonna be a big deal and
it's going to happen on the big screen
not really as a cameo in a television
series but that's just my opinion but we
do need to address the aerospace
engineer because it is being hyped up to
be something big
and that leads us into our number four
theory which as best as i can tell
originated on twitter by jimmy foleno
under the handle
at mr niceguy513 so fans who have
rejected the notion of reed richards
being featured in one division have
proposed an alternative theory as to the
aerospace engineer's identity which i
think is far more likely and
far more awesome proponents of this
theory put forward the idea
that the identity of the aerospace
engineer is
adam bashir now if you are not an avid
marvel comics fan this name might not
mean
anything to you and what a shame because
comic book readers will know how
awesome this inclusion in the series
would be adam beshear
is the real name of the blue marvel one
of the most powerful characters in
marvel comics a guy who even one shot
the hulk and a marvel comics continuity
marvel's first african-american
superhero now i make this distinction
because in the real world timeline
falcon is marvel's first published
african-american superhero as he debuted
in 1969 compared to 2008 for blue
marvel but when blue marvel was
introduced it was revealed that he'd
been operating within the marvel
universe
long before any of the modern day
superheroes showed up and so in novel
comics the way brochure gets his powers
comes from the fact that he's an ivy
league educated scientist
working on an experiment involving
anti-matter and when the machine
explodes he basically becomes a living
anti-matter reactor what does this mean
it basically means he can channel
unlimited energy and this is interesting
because blue marvel is again
one of the most powerful heroes in
marvel comics and if done right would
probably be the most powerful hero in
the mcu
until they introduce hyperion and so i
think it would be awesome to see him on
screen although i assume that if he is
the aerospace engineer being referenced
he likely doesn't have his powers yet in
the mcu but it will set up the idea that
we'll be seeing blue marvel in the
marvel cinematic universe relatively
soon now at number three we have a
theory that i've talked about a few
times here which is that one division is
basically setting up the idea of the
marvel multiverse to bring in the x-men
from the fox universe to the mcu and so
in marvel comics the multiverse is
exactly what it sounds like multiple
unique universes existing simultaneously
and we know this concept is coming to
the mcu with a second doctor strange
movie so the idea here is that the fox
x-men films exist
within a parallel universe to the mcu
and something will happen that breaks
down the barrier between universes and
the fox x-men will come to the mcu the
first clue of this happening
is pretty obvious which is evan peters
who played quicksilver in the fox films
showing up in the role of pietro
maximoff and while i suppose this could
be a straight recast of the character
it would be a bizarre choice out of all
the actors they could pick
to catch the one that had portrayed the
character in the x-men films
unless there are plans for the character
down the road including using him to
introduce the rest of the x-men with
what's been revealed
since evan peters first appeared namely
that wanda has figured out that he's not
really pietro and the fact that he seems
to be working or has been put there by
agatha harkness based on the mid-credit
scene of episode number seven this seems
a bit less likely
but i don't think we can reject the
theory altogether a more subtle piece of
evidence to support this theory centers
around
tyler hayward the director of sword and
i found this theory actually being
advanced by tick tock user straw hat
goofy so this theory
centers around the idea that at first
hayward and monica seem to have a really
good relationship with one another and
then all of a sudden the relationship
becomes very tense so what changed well
hayward knows that monica's dna has been
altered by entering westfield and he
knows this before anybody else does
why would this matter well if hayward
comes from the universe where the x-men
and mutants exist
he would likely hate and fear the mutant
race which is pretty much the entire
plot of the x-men story since the team's
creation
and hayward appears to have a great
distrust for super powered beings he
really doesn't like wanda he doesn't
seem to even give her any credit for
like
helping save the world he just treats
her like a straight up villain and he
interrogates jimmy wu about wanda
repeatedly asking if she has any kind of
a nickname or alias
almost as if he knows that she's
supposed to is this because he knows her
as the scarlet witch despite her never
being referred to as scarlet witch in
the mcu but maybe she is in the universe
that he comes from where the x-men exist
some fans think so but i think that's a
stretch as we never saw wanda in the
x-men films with the exception of days
of future past
and she was like three but we know that
the x-men will be making their way to
the mcu eventually and while everybody
always assumed they would all be recast
maybe the plan really is to introduce
the fox x-men everyone's already
familiar with now at number two we have
the theory that has probably had the
most
buzz ever since the premise of the show
was revealed and that is that some
entity more powerful than wanda
is really pulling the strings here with
the most popular theory centering around
mephisto now i've explained who mephisto
is in a few different videos here on
this channel and even more in depth
on my other channel comics explained but
the quick and dirty explanation here is
that he's the ruler of a section of hell
in the marvel universe and he and wanda
have quite a history together especially
as it relates to her two sons
billy and tommy and what we learn in the
comics is that wanda
actually formed her sons out of pieces
of mephisto soul and their appearance in
the show has actually led to a great
deal of speculation that mephisto's
going to show up in wand division and
possibly set him up to be the big bad in
doctor strange too and fans are spotting
easter eggs that they think
hint at mephisto's eventual arrival all
over the place the independent
highlights a few of these
for instance when wanda sees a fly on
the curtain in episode number seven a
lot of fans are suggesting that could be
a reference to mephisto who appeared in
an issue of the current avengers run in
the form of a fly but i
think that actually being a reference to
mephisto would take a degree of
coordination between the film and comic
sides that we simply haven't seen before
as that issue
just came out last year and likely
wouldn't have been known by the
producers of the show
and many fans have also theorized that
agatha's often mentioned but never seen
husband ralph maybe mephisto himself
others are focusing on agatha's pet
rabbit senior scratchy theorizing he
could be mephisto in disguise as in the
past
mephisto was gone by the alias next
scratch now fans have also pointed out
the mysterious mailman that seems to
keep showing up at various times who in
episode 7
wore a uniform with the name presto on
the shirt and a rabbit logo on his hat
however i think the senor scratchy is
actually just a reference to agatha's
son nicholas scratch who is a
stupidly powerful wizard in marvel
comics and a character that i feel like
we should explain on comics explains but
whether this is just an easter egg for
comic book fans or is
actually leading to nicholas scratch
coming to the mcu remains to be seen
but i think that's the most likely
inspiration for the rabbit's name
instead of it being a reference to
mephisto
now we are at our number one theory and
i think this one
could be the biggest for the future of
the mcu
in episode number seven we see a
commercial for an anti-depressant called
nexus which i think is going to be
significant and this could mean
one of two things both of which were
pointed out in a recent article by comic
book resources
one is the nexus of all realities which
is a point at which multiple realities
converge and this could basically just
be more
evidence of the multiverse coming to the
mcu and would explain
how evan peter's version of quicksilver
showed up in one division and the
commercial even says that nexus will
keep you anchored to reality or any
reality of your choice so it's a very
good possibility that this is a
reference
to the next of all realities another
possibility is that it's a reference to
wanda's status as a nexus being now in
marvel comics wanda was selected to be
the nexus being of the marvel universe
which is basically the person that
serves as the focal point of all the
magical energy of a given universe and
so i think that this is setting up wanda
as the mcu's nexus being and here's
where things potentially get interesting
in the comics nexus beings are so
powerful
that they have to be monitored by
multiversal agencies like the time
variance authority and what's
significant about this is that the tva
is confirmed to be a central part of the
upcoming loki series on disney plus
now this next part actually comes from
my writer ryan and he demanded that i
put this in the video
he wanted credit now going back to
elizabeth olsen teasing a luke skywalker
level cameo for one division
that could be a reference to tom
hiddleston showing up as loki as the
time variants authority is getting
involved in monitoring wanda as a
potential nexus being furthermore paul
bettany has said that as part of wand
division he got to share the screen with
an actor that he'd not been on screen
with before and that the two of them
had amazing chemistry now most people
have interpreted this as being benedict
cumberbatch who plays doctor strange but
it could simply just be loki
who at least as far as i can tell has
not been on screen
with vision throughout the entirety of
the marvel cinematic universe and
bringing loki in would be a very typical
mcu move as their post-credits scenes
often set up new movies and so having
loki show up near the end of juan
division would be a great way to set up
the loki series
and establish a connection between the
various disney plus series and so i
think
that's a big possibility that not a lot
of people are talking about despite how
much sense it makes
and that's why it's our number one
theory with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you let us
know we'll do more top five videos on
whatever things you guys think are
interesting and make sure you guys check
out our video playlist on one division
easter eggs theories and all that kind
of good stuff we will catch you all
later
peace